here in the u.s holiday travel is
surging at the same time coronavirus
numbers skyrocket more than one million
people have passed through tsa airport
checkpoints
in each of the past two days despite cdc
guidance
that we all stay home for christmas
errol barnett is in memphis tennessee a
state
that now has the nation's highest number
of new covet cases per capita good
morning errol
good morning well consider this covert
cases here in tennessee are up
14 in the past week and that's why there
are warnings now that a holiday surge
could completely break the health care
system the governor in a special address
sunday night did issue new statewide
restrictions on gatherings
but fell short of enacting a mask
mandate and that's why doctors we're
speaking with are fearful
things are about to get worse i think
we're playing a very dangerous game of
chicken
dr stephen threlkeld says now is crunch
time for people in tennessee
warning the coveted vaccine is a light
of hope but only if people keep wearing
masks
and socially distance there's no
question that there will be people alive
next holiday season if they do the
things that we need to do
this holiday season tennessee is one of
a handful of states
without a statewide mask mandate and
despite his wife testing positive for
covert 19 over the weekend governor bill
lee
stopped short of issuing a statewide
order on sunday
instead issuing this call to action
masks
work and i want every tennessean
to wear one heading into christmas week
the spreading concern is twofold
americans getting together for the
holidays and the travel involved to get
there
[Music]
concern became reality for passengers of
united flight 591
many now concerned they were exposed to
kovid
after a man fell ill on their flight
from orlando to los angeles
this video obtained by tmz shows
passengers performing cpr on the man
in the aisle tony aldappa was one of the
passengers who jumped into action
there were three of us that were
essentially tag teaming
doing chest compressions the man later
died at the hospital
united says all customers on that flight
acknowledged they had not been diagnosed
with covert 19 in the past two weeks
and did not have any symptoms al dapper
says the man's wife
told him otherwise she told me he was
short of breath
and she just wanted to get him home
united says it's working with the cdc to
determine if anyone was exposed to
covert 19.
days after the ordeal al dapa says he
now has covered symptoms
as of saturday he is not tested positive
it comes down to personal accountability
if you if you're traveling right now you
know the risks
of traveling
now aaa predicts more than 84 million
americans will travel between wednesday
and january third while that is a thirty
percent decrease from this time
last year it is more than 30 million
americans additional
from the folks who traveled during
thanksgiving just a few weeks ago
vlad all right errol thank you very much
the